what i'm really saying is there's a lot
of guys
running around as red pill [ __ ]
there's no other better way to
say it you're simping you're basically
simping for
um other creators or you're simply while
not doing anything yourself you know
they're simply for women they're sipping
for guys believe it or not
a great example of simping for men uh
you see them
on uh all over elon musk anytime he says
says anything buy this token
see what he did with dogecoin and see
what he did with bitcoin he knew full
well
when he made that tweet talking about
energy consumption
what he was going on about and what he
was doing but all the sheep
they're simping for elon musk gotta buy
his cars
you know fly those rockets let's all go
watch the rockets take off
they're just simping for the guy it's a
perfect example of it
all right whoa we got a lot of guys
piling into the
waiting area let me know in the private
chat guys uh what is you want to talk
about what pointers you want to hit or
add on if you have an experience or
just a question so the two things that
you'll start to notice men do in this
space
this men's self-improvement space is
they'll just sit
and watch two different things that
they'll watch
they'll either watch drama unfold it's
like the jerry springer
of um i don't know if you guys remember
jerry springer maybe that's dating me
but he used to run this talk show
and one of the more common topics he
would have would be uh
you know is it your baby sort of
episodes
and you know hypergamy you know alpha
[ __ ] beta bucks sort of things you'd
see it unfold
right in front of you on jerry springer
and it was just the indignation
it was a drama and they get on fights on
stage and have security come in and it
was just
it was just a total train wreck and you
see a lot of guys
in the um the sphere if you will the
manual swamp as i like to call it is
what it
what it's turned into chasing drama
and it's like they'll go from one guy to
the next guy to the next guy and it's
like oh
you know let's see who he's talking
about over here oh there's a video on
this guy over here and i don't think i
like this guy so let me watch it
and it's hilarious because a lot of the
times you know dudes will send me uh
you know an email or a dm and they'd be
like oh somebody did a video on you that
you got to see it's
you know it's a hit piece like dude i
don't even have time to watch videos of
my friends
some of my friends are on youtube you
guys already know that and i don't even
have time to watch
their [ __ ] half the time why would i
waste my time and resources
watching some muppet make up [ __ ] right
get in the ring see you guys have
noticed or you should have noticed by
now
over the last month or so i've been
inviting
haters to come on onto the show with
what it is that they want to talk about
okay they're always like oh i have a
better solution your problem okay
click the link join in let's hear what
your solution is but have you seen one
come on
in the last two months not one not one
i've had people that wanted to discuss
some ideas in an intelligent fashion
which was wonderful
but i haven't had a hater be like hey
look man i got a way better solution
than you you're an idiot this is my
solution boom
doesn't exist does not exist
i've got a quick super chat here frank
soon
sun atra that's sunatra already reading
through the first chapter book loving it
shears all the way from kitchener
shout out to kitchener waterloo twin
cities
it's about three hours away from me
west southwest um
so you got the drama part of it which
you guys see all the time
you know there's there's there's pieces
on me friends of mine it's like
and i've said this many times before and
it bears repeating again
hate only ever comes from beneath you
nobody ever gets jealous of losers it's
always somebody that admires and envies
you
and rather than doing the work to build
an audience in a productive fashion and
deliver useful content
what they do is they manufacture drama
the other side of that too is you see a
lot of drama
in the sense of oh look at this
article look at this whatever and
this is why you should just completely
avoid women guys just stay away and just
completely avoid women because this
article or this
and it's just going to be a total
nightmare for you but they don't offer
any real solutions
right so you got to ask yourself am i
sitting in the stadium
learning anything if you're not why are
you watching it
okay if you're sitting in the stadium
and you're learning something great
now what i want you to do is rather than
go to the next channel the next guy the
next content creator and
the next and the next next actually get
in the [ __ ] arena and start doing
something
with the knowledge that you've acquired
i can't tell you how many guys will
approach me and ask me for help
and try to get feedback on something
they're stuck on yeah
mops in the chat dogs only bark at
moving cars exactly
and um you know help me out with this
that and the other thing it's like
i feel like i should make it a
prerequisite can you do at least 30
push-ups
10 chin-ups and skip rope for
five minutes or run a mile or something
like that like can you do basic [ __ ]
like that
before you start asking me to help you
get the girls
right there's a lot of work guys need to
do internally and sitting in the stadium
in the bleachers watching other people
chase excellence while you sit there and
just
one of the things that drives me nuts is
like when you see guys at
you know after sporting events like yeah
we won
we won we won no you didn't dude you
didn't play the game you sat in the
[ __ ] bleachers and you clapped
you get what i'm saying there's another
form of
sitting it out and drama and indignation
that that we've seen a lot more of these
days especially in the last
year and it's let's see if we can own
these girls let's see if we can make
them look bad let's hold them
accountable
men stop trying to hold women
hold yourself accountable when you get
up in the morning you look in the mirror
and that man looks back at you hold that
guy accountable
stop trying to hold women accountable
stop consuming red meat where you're
like
yeah he got her taught her a lesson
flames
boom yeah
what are you learning from that tell me
what are you learning from that
are you there for entertainment fine
entertain yourself but are you in the
ring
entertain yourself all day long i'll you
know i'll kick back
i'll throw on a show you know what i've
been watching lately that i've really
enjoyed
i really like jeremy clarkson okay big
fan of top gear
the grand tour he's got a uh he's got a
series on amazon now called clarkson's
farm
so i'll be kicking back you know
enjoying that but guess what i am in
the arena i am on the floor i am playing
the game
okay i'm not just sitting on the
sidelines entertaining myself
so be careful with that okay don't sit
on the sidelines
consuming entertainment drama and red
meat
when you got nothing going on the floor
can you do at least 30 push-ups straight
can you do those 10 put
those 10 cent up straight can you skip
rope for three to five minutes without
tripping or losing your breath and
falling over
most guys can't you know
where's my book
i know i've talked about it it's an
important read
the feedback has been phenomenal one of
the things i talk about my book and i've
talked about in other videos is you have
you have an obligation as a man to do
something of some significance i don't
care what your dent in the universe
looks like i don't care if you go the
steve
jobs route and completely change
handheld telecommunications
i don't care if you go the elon musk
route and build electric cars and
[ __ ] rockets
i don't care if you're the guy down the
street that makes the best gelato
that i've ever had right i don't care
put a dent in the universe figure out
what that purpose is that you need to go
about doing for yourself
right it sure is [ __ ] not sitting around
watching other people chase excellence
or do something and here's the other
thing too
like a lot of guys like to uh rich
you're a snake oil salesman man you're a
[ __ ]
you're making all this money off the
script of course that's my favorite one
lately i don't promote anything anymore
right now except for
uh charlie and miguel's cultivate crypto
course which i
should actually mention uh because it
does close close tonight if you're on my
email list you would have got an email
about that i rarely email it i
normally send out a video monthly with
my uh behind the paywall premium content
that i'm slowly releasing over time so
if you want to get on my email list
i should probably put up the banner
where is it
there it is ticker okay i'll leave that
up you should get on that email list
you get the free chapter in the red
flags and you'll also be able to stay in
communication whenever i've got an offer
or something like that anyway
so uh you're ripping off people with
this cryptocurrency course
dude just don't buy it i don't [ __ ]
care stay poor
you know stay uninformed trust the
government if if if that's what you
think the solution is to
the world's debt problems and money and
securing your financial future
why don't you just trust the government
let the government take care of you
you know because because they're good
because they've done a really good job
at it
if that's what you want to do do that it
doesn't matter but people get so worked
up and bent out of shape
right and they go on manufactured
dignation and drama
man i got a thousand free videos on my
channel i take call-in shows and help
people out publicly for free
ah you're a show though because you're
talking about a cryptocurrency course
anyway let me grab the link for that
since i'm such a shill i might as well i
may as well maintain that reputation
right
uh do crypto predictions there's the
video i did the other day
and if you are interested
do yourself a solid and get this thing
yes
it's an affiliate link yes yes yes yes
anyway there it is closes at midnight
tonight it is worth its weight in gold
or don't buy it i don't care it doesn't
matter to me if you
if you think stonks are better by amc
by gamestop by bars of gold if you think
that that's
a better solution do it doesn't matter
to me
you